it's really starting to feel like we're
in the middle of an animation
Renaissance and I honestly hope that
this is only the beginning after the
incredible success of the first
spiderverse movie I really feel like a
lot of the production world has really
begun to wake up to the power and
flexibility of Animation as a medium
again the amount of incredible visually
diverse animated projects we are seeing
at the Forefront lately really is rising
and not in the animation is Cinema sort
of way don't get me wrong there's been
plenty of incredibly well-made animated
works for kids lately but even outside
of those you have shows like scavengers
rain and blueeyed Samurai delivering
impeccable animation and Designs making
the most of their medium all without
being Shackled to the E for everyone
rating but I guess my greater point is
just that animation is a medium it has
strengths and advantages inherent to it
and I am glad to be seeing these really
taken advantage of in all forms more and
more now rather than the medium being
Shackled to Disney Princesses Pixar and
SpongeBob not that there's anything
wrong with SpongeBob